so
um again for the for the
viewer remember I was you were you were
asking me where's do you have a quad
drill it's like well the quad is working
even in the Stillness drills but
definitely in this inward spiral outward
spiral drill okay and especially in the
video where you're trying to free the
shoulder so in that video I mentioned
how look the look at my midsection it's
moving well there's there's no way it's
moving if the if the quaw is not moving
the quaw has to move okay and again for
simple for Simplicity to just start out
I would like for you to think of the qua
as this crease in your pelvis between
your pelvis and your upper thighs and I
would like for you to think of it it
closes on one side and opens the on the
other the crease gets tight and on the
other side the crease will open okay and
so when you free your
shoulder as the shoulder goes back it I
it's not right if my quad on that
homolateral side does not move with it
so I'm not I don't keep my qua still and
I free my shoulder that's that's not
what I'm doing
okay the quad on the homolateral side
releases just like the shoulder release
so you want to look here forget the arm
we already went over the arm forget the
shoulder we already went over the the
shoulder you want to see
that with what we did in the arm which I
was doing that whole
even I'll try to keep my other and I
exaggerate now there's always going to
be in in cooku like we have cooku drills
and uh there's me
generating um more positive y so maybe I
come forward you see to do it but that's
not how you use it in in a technique in
a technique he always presses into the
positive y so he presses in to the coou
point okay and so towards that end
there's always a yield I always have to
load the Coq Point okay so it's not that
I'm here and then I push him forward
like if that's where you're at that's
where you're at okay you're still
working the physiological coordination
which is important you have to do that
okay but as I go back boom is where he
hits the ground path and that's what you
want to learn learn okay so as as we
keep
go boom it can make those movements
smaller cuz what I'm doing is if like if
the Harlem glow Trotters used to get
that ball and it hit their bicep it's
it's like that you're loading the ground
Vector with the yin boom Yin okay and
the harder it pushes the hard rate
pushes like use all your muscle it just
gets it gets easier because there's more
now loow onto the ground top okay it's
as opposed to if you try if you're doing
it the other way the harder he pushes
the harder that gets okay which is
always a thing like people always say
what if he really pushed or what if he
really attacked it gets easier okay so
you have a couple of ways okay I'll just
work on freeing the shoulder but also
freeing that homolateral crease and
bringing it back
you could do that and you should all
that is good for you but after you get
it you want to think of the loading boom
load boom load when you feel it load is
when you come back and load that's where
I feel it that's where I boom come okay
got and that's a whole other level but
mechanically in terms of the qu those
creases on your shoulder it is the same
say okay this you have to on your own
feel the internals I can't get you there
off of video okay but you can work on
this and you should because a lot of you
are stiffies and you you move like this
and you should not you should go this
can't be right this this doesn't even
feel right I don't feel well I feel very
old okay you you should be Supple supple
Supple your whole you could think of it
that your whole life is is a life of
gaining and remaining Supple and that
could be the way
okay this
into previous videos okay so if I'm
going into EO you can see that
externally that qua is moving do you see
this qua over here open
okay but you should
still also do it so I I don't just step
there and that's it just going to be the
movement
okay so as I go well there it is you see
and then you
have we do that side
again okay we're here I know we already
did a video on that I got to let him go
by and then I project up into the front
inward position we pay the clock okay so
one out there it is and it comes
okay do it slow so
out okay
here don't lock it there and then move
your arm
it's
connected
out in now this side is closed okay in I
go out and it's going to go with my arm
the shoulder the free shoulder I use the
free shoulder Bo and it
does
and for
others this
hand is used don't take EO and make it
the other drill and then you come in and
do
this yes the other drill is in EO but EO
is not the other drill so I have my hand
you see the Tami there's the drill right
here right there
okay
this hand's not grabbing okay I got to
do one more inward spiral which you do
by rotating L gong one more time here is
your outer spiral so this elbow comes
in we know my elbow comes in do you see
so I go
again
boom boom don't grabb it it but it's
there I do one more
spiral then the inward then the
outward it's there don't have it here
and then there it's already there one
more
spiral and I go bring my elbow
in and that's just to
stop doing
this smooth to
hands because it's the hour
SP here the technique goes on but we're
not going on
all right let's
[Music]
try are you still filming here's another
one I
hate you going to do EO do
EO then you come in what the [\h__\h] is
that okay EO you're in the
relationship stay in
there so what we're trying to we're
obviously trying to do the ritual again
you say we're trying to do the energetic
ritual but the energetic ritual is
concentric with the Marshal ritual so
he's got his grip on there I can't pull
that off unless I'm stronger than him do
you see so one more turn one more turn
which is really just start your in start
the outer spiral I ran out to the end of
the inward spiral start the out spiral
do you see this part I'm here I go like
this w that's the inward the outward
spiral then you keep around again and
then look I'm falling out
okay so we're trying to get out of that
outer delto okay Mo around and you're
you're going to be out you can't hold
that okay now this hand too this is
going to be outer deltoid again holy cow
that hurts okay
Instead This elbow comes in and it's
just because I move that it looks like
it's not happening but because I go
inside of
it it looks like I did the other thing
but it's wrong okay I'm still spiral
rotating right on
that so now watch that elbow more on
that hand on it's right hand
do that side
again it's right
here there this
way
right this
way okay try again